Transcription: Freya Villain
Relecteur: eric vautier
J’ai un aveu à vous faire :
je suis timide.
Je sais ce que vous vous dites :
pour commencer à prendre la parole devant
300 personnes, ce n’est pas l’idéal.
Quand on est timide,
on ne fait pas un TED.
Je vais donc préciser.
Quand j’étais petite, j’étais timide,
vraiment timide,
à tel point que je trouvais des stratégies
pour éviter certaines situations.
Un jour, ma mère m’a demandé
d’aller acheter du pain
dans la boulangerie
en bas de mon immeuble.
Maman, je sais que tu es dans
la salle mais n’écoute pas la suite.
Je suis descendue en bas de chez moi,
j’ai attendu quelques minutes,
avant de remonter,
en disant à ma mère que
la boulangerie était fermée
tellement j’avais peur de demander
deux baguettes à la boulangère.
Quelques années après,
j’ai prononcé un discours à l’Unesco
devant 1 300 personnes.
Qu’est-ce qui a permis de passer
de cette petite fille timide et réservée
à cette adolescente
beaucoup plus sûre d’elle ?
C’est tout simplement
l’engagement que j’ai eu.
Et c’est de ça dont je vais vous
parler ce soir : l’engagement.
En disant le mot « engagement »,
peut-être que beaucoup d’entre vous
pensent aux couples, voire au mariage.
Je vous rassure, je ne vais demander
personne en direct ce soir au TED,
et je suis célibataire,
donc je ne m’y connais vraiment pas.
Je vais parler d’un engagement
que je connais un peu mieux :
l’engagement associatif.
Pour ça, revenons quelques années
en arrière, à l’école primaire,
l’époque où pour moi,
les boulangeries étaient fermées.
Les enfants voulaient jouer
au foot, à la poupée,
rentrer vite de l’école
pour regarder des dessins animés.
Moi, j’avais un projet que les enfants
trouvaient un peu moins fun :
être élue au conseil municipal
des enfants de Palaiseau.
Je ne vais pas faire de suspense,
je n’ai pas été élue.
Mais ce n’est pas grave, l’engagement,
ce n’est pas une compétition.
Il ne s’agit pas d’être
le premier ou la première
mais d’apprendre à chaque étape.
D’ailleurs, quelques années après,
j’ai réussi à intégrer
le conseil des jeunes de Palaiseau.
Je sais, vous vous dites
que j’ai commencé à m’engager
parce que j’avais plein d’idées, de rêves,
que je voulais changer le monde.
Et pas du tout, pas du tout.
Je voulais simplement passer un peu
plus de temps avec mon frère
qui était dans ce conseil.
L’engagement, c’est aussi créer
des liens plus forts avec les autres,
tisser des relations ou des amitiés
très intenses
en travaillant sur un même projet.
Je me suis donc engagée un peu par hasard,
sans trop savoir où cette aventure
allait me mener.
Vous n’avez pas besoin d’avoir
la tête pleine d’idées ou de rêves
pour commencer à vous engager.
J’ai appris tellement de choses
en m’engageant,
surtout des choses que l’on ne nous
apprend pas forcément à l’école :
comment prendre la parole en public,
structurer un discours,
monter un projet,
animer un atelier ou un débat.
Et de toutes ces compétences
et ces connaissances acquises,
j’ai réussi à monter mon propre projet.
J’ai créé une association qui s’appelle
« Tes potes engagés »
qui vise à promouvoir et à valoriser
l’engagement des jeunes.
C’est aussi pour ça
que je suis là ce soir :
je crois en l’engagement des jeunes,
en la valeur de l’engagement des jeunes,
et surtout, je crois que l’engagement
des jeunes a de la valeur pour tous,
y compris les moins jeunes.
Cette association est pour moi
un nouveau terrain de jeu
dans lequel je peux m’amuser
tout en défendant
des choses qui me tiennent à cœur.
Et j’insiste sur ce verbe, s’amuser,
car pour moi, aucun engagement
ne doit être une contrainte.
En effet, combien de fois
m’a-t-on demandé :
« Mais pourquoi tu vas à une réunion le
soir au lieu de sortir avec tes amis ?
Tu ne veux pas faire un truc de jeunes ?
A quoi ça te sert tout ça ? »
Vous le pensez un peu, vous aussi ?
Je vais vous faire un autre aveu.
C’est qu’en allant
à cette réunion le soir,
je retrouve mes amis,
et je me sens épanouie,
parce que l’engagement
aide dans cette voie.
Il aide à se sentir légitime,
à vaincre sa timidité aussi.
Vous vous souvenez les baguettes
quand j’étais petite ?
De mon côté, l’engagement m’a surtout
montré où était ma place
et comment me sentir
utile dans la société.
En définitive, l’engagement m’a permis
de vaincre mes propres limites
que je m’étais fixées
quand j’étais petite.
Et puis, en m’engageant, en montant
un projet, je me lie aux autres,
j’évolue, je grandis
et je travaille sur des thématiques
qui touchent directement les jeunes.
Donc en fait, si, je fais
un « truc de jeunes ».
Mais du coup, c’est ça, un truc de jeunes.
On peut essayer de le valoriser aussi,
expliquer aux adultes qu’être jeune
et engagé apporte beaucoup.
Tout comme être jeune et musicien
ou jeune et sportif.
Visiblement, ce TEDx est aussi pour moi
l’occasion de transformer
toutes ces frustrations que j’ai pu vivre
ces dernières années,
quand je n’avais pas
aussi confiance en moi
pour expliquer aux autres
tout ce en quoi je crois.
C’est aussi pour ça
que je suis là ce soir.
Si en quittant la salle,
vous sentez qu’il est important
qu’un jeune puisse s’engager,
en tant que jeune,
pour lui-même et pour le monde,
si vous vous sentez prêt et disponible
à accompagner ce jeune
qui souhaite s’engager,
alors j’aurai relevé mon défi.
Je vais me permettre ici
de reprendre une phrase
que j’ai entendue pour la 1e fois
dans la bouche de Grand Corps Malade.
Cette phrase ne vient peut-être pas de lui
mais ça me permet de le citer ici.
Cette phrase dit : « Tout seul,
je vais vite, ensemble, on va loin. »
Ensemble.
Ensemble, on pourrait faire
plein de choses, non ?
On est 300 dans la salle ici,
et je suis persuadée que
si chacune et chacun d’entre nous,
et les personnes qui regardent en ligne,
prenions part dès maintenant à un projet
citoyen ou à une action collective,
nous pourrions changer beaucoup de choses.
D’ailleurs, c’est un peu ça,
l’idée d’un TED, non ?
« Ideas worth spreading. »
Ou plus simplement en français :
« Des idées qui méritent
d’être répandues. »
C’est un peu finir par agir, non ?
Pourquoi ce n’est pas si simple ?
Pourquoi l’engagement
n’est pas une évidence ?
Il me semble ici important
de vous parler des difficultés
que j’ai pu rencontrer en m’engageant.
Car oui,
s’engager n’est pas toujours rose.
Mais croyez-moi, ça vaut vraiment le coup.
Tout d’abord, le manque de crédibilité.
Il peut arriver qu’un projet
qu’on veuille monter
ne plaise pas
ou que les autres n’y croient pas.
J’ai beaucoup douté de moi et de mes idées
mais finalement tout ça m’a permis
de les renforcer
et je suis aujourd’hui plus sûre que
jamais de mes valeurs et de mes projets.
Ensuite, il y a le manque
de reconnaissance
qui peut être difficile à gérer
surtout quand des grandes structures
ne prévoient pas ou peu d’aménagements
pour l’engagement associatif.
Et enfin, de ce manque de reconnaissance
peuvent découler des problèmes de gestion
du temps, pour arriver à tout concilier.
Et pourtant,
ce n’est pas une politique de fond
contre l’engagement des jeunes.
Y a-t-il quelqu’un dans la salle
qui est contre l’engagement des jeunes ?
Non, personne n’est contre
l’engagement des jeunes.
La difficulté, c’est qu’on n’y pense pas.
Par exemple, dans mon université,
pour avoir une dispense
pour un cours ou pour une journée,
il y a trois cases :
sport de haut niveau,
job étudiant, ou handicap.
Du coup, je passe des heures
à obtenir des documents,
à demander des attestations,
à envoyer des mails,
et à attendre
des autorisations exceptionnelles.
Alors qu’il suffirait d’y penser,
de savoir que ça existe,
que c’est important pour
chacune et chacun d’entre nous,
il suffirait de penser à laisser
une quatrième case « engagement ».
Chacun est en mesure de laisser cette
quatrième case dans nos universités,
mais aussi au travail ou en famille,
dans les cercles qui sont les vôtres.
Il est important que chacun en parle pour
que les jeunes sachent que c'est possible.
Pour que les enfants de l’école primaire
puissent jouer au foot,
encore faut-il qu’ils sachent
que ce sport existe.
C’est pareil pour l’engagement.
Ensuite, il n’y a plus qu’à laisser un peu
de place humainement et socialement,
et un peu de place dans l’agenda.
S’engager,
c’est le début d’une aventure humaine
très belle à découvrir.
Il y a à mon sens autant de façons de
s'engager que de jeunes qui s'engagent.
Chacun peut y trouver sa place.
Il suffit de penser à laisser disponible
cette quatrième case,
la place pour ce dans quoi
un jeune veut s’engager.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)